chuck i'm back
in your face yes yes you are or at least
virtually
virtually in your face yes i want to
talk about when food goes bad
okay so you're already you got me i love
it when food goes bad
because something i'm very well aware of
because i come from
a childhood where mom
and grandmom almost refuse to almost
throw away
i mean to freeze their throw away they
didn't want to waste food they don't
want to never
even if the food would kill you they
wouldn't throw in the food
i'm just like mom this thing is moving
what are you talking about you know
well you put that in the pan it'll be
just fine
dang number little molds burn that right
back up you cut that mold off of there
you that's just fine
these are people who like grew up in the
depression you know and where hunger was
a thing
yeah so they don't want them young
whipper snappers just throwing away food
it's like how dare you waste food and
one of my favorite
comics was gary larson and the subtitle
was
when the potato salad goes bad and you
go inside the refrigerator
the potato salad's got a gun and it's
holding it up to the lead it's not funny
it's like mugging other food when it
goes bad right
it shows the right thing the potato
salad right because that's the one you
gotta watch out for exactly
so why am i an astrophysicist talking
about that i'll tell you why
because there's the normal kind of way
food goes bad
all right you leave it in there too long
and something grows
on it all right something else
wants to eat the food and it's some kind
of microbe
some bacteria or combination of bacteria
that start eating the food and
it could be mold that's enjoying the
food that you were going to eat
all right now first of all
there's this bacteria's on the food all
the time it's just a matter of how much
is there
right and you have a digestive tract and
depending on what you ate the food will
take a certain amount of time to go from
your mouth
to come out the other side or to get
metabolized all right so
if you ingest bacteria on your food that
would otherwise be bad for you
that bacteria begins to multiply all
right it's multiplying at some rate
in the refrigerator but when it warms up
to your body temperature
because you've just eaten it it will
duplicate faster
okay so there it is duplicate now it's
in your throat and it's in your stomach
do you play faster
it's in your your small intestine you're
larger and says if it gets out
before it takes over then you don't even
think anything of it
no it's no problem it's no problem so
but these thresholds
where if you in just a certain amount
the doubling time of that bacteria
will then manifest itself while it's
still in your digestive tract
and then you end up with nausea you know
diarrhea whatever
okay so that's sort of normal food
poisoning
all right normal and we also we have
we've developed a means to
detect by the smell when something goes
bad okay evolutionarily
if you casually ingested things that
would make you sick and
possibly die if you enjoyed the smell of
rotting food
that's a branch that is a genetic branch
that's headed for extinction
because right because you and all your
descendants who like the smell of
rotting food that would kill you
you would end up with none of you to
then propagate this
feature about yourself all right so we
do unless you're a vulture
unless you're a culture right right but
they they're cool but they're cool with
it
depending on you know how digestive your
gastric juices are
from one species to another for humans
we know what those limits are
you smell it that's bad and you throw it
away except for your mama
that's right all right so that's the
normal
kind of when food goes bad all right but
suppose you got rid of all the microbes
and then you sort of vacuum sealed it
nothing no microbes anyway and you put
it in a really cold temperature
because all as far as we have been able
to measure
chemical and biological processes
double their rate every 10 degrees
celsius okay okay that's why cooling
things make them last longer
right that's right so you can do this
you can so does it mean it stops at zero
it would have to stop yes okay zero yes
nothing happened nothing
nothing happens absolute zero oh no i
don't mean absolute zero i mean if you
just start you say every 10 degrees
celsius oh okay yeah so you it would
stop at absolute zero
at absolute zero oh you think zero just
on the underneath yeah i was thinking on
a regular
there's nothing special about that zero
the only special zero is on a kelvin
absolute scale and we did a whole
explainer video it and we got a link
we put a link in there somewhere okay
that's right that's right all right
so every 10 degrees it's half so you can
just keep having all the way down
okay so you can do the experiment if you
wanted you know have
uh get milk and bring it to room
temperature okay
then get milk put it at um in the
refrigerator temperature
and they get milk put it like right at
near freezing
and then get milk and just freeze it and
just sit back and just watch what
happens
all right the microbes that are already
in it are doing their thing
and you can look at the temperature
differences and you can calculate this
up and basically the milk might last a
day or two
if oh by the way what is ultra
pasteurized mean
ultra pasteurized they they took out
even more microbes than were there in
the normal pasteurized
wow okay now what now with twice as
little
twice as little i would say half as much
but you can say twice as little all
right that's fine
so when you do that the pasteurized
smoke look at the expiration date
on the ultra pasteurized milk versus the
regular pasteurized milk
it's way longer in the future because
there's so few
microbes there they're slowly coming
along and they're doubling time they
still have a doubling time
all right but they started out with
fewer so they're not going to get there
this milk smells nasty threshold until
much later
okay so that's the biological when food
goes bad
but i want to take this up a notch
okay go ahead let us get rid of all
microbes
let us irradiate the food all right so
now there's
nothing living on it at all now we don't
want anything to come
to it after the fact so now let's vacuum
seal it
okay so now nothing's getting to it
nothing's on it
okay so now i have a slab of meat vacuum
sealed okay
now i don't have to refrigerate it
because there's no microbes that i don't
i can put out on the counter i can put
it up in the cabinet
okay you can put it there for years
and years and years
you know why i know about this and think
about it because when you're going to
store
food on a long space mission
you don't want to carry freezers with
you in refrigerators
you want food that can just stay
you want food that could just survive on
the shelf that could just
be b you need food that just is that
food that
is right you need your steak to be a
twinkie
i'm i'm eating twinkie steak twinkies
from eight years ago
just the same as i bought them yesterday
right
my steak is good for 20 years all right
so but here's what happens okay right
and this is where quantum physics comes
in
so you didn't see that coming did you i
did not you did not see that coming all
right you
you totally had me all right so
molecules
exist in a state of existence all right
all molecules do
and you can ask yourself is the molecule
happy in that state of existence
is it happy in other words
is there a lower state of energy
that this molecule can occupy
because if there is it's going to want
to go there
is that state of energy i'm such a big
molecule let me break into
two now i have less energy than before
because
molecules don't like remaining in higher
states of vendor
and those two molecules can break and
then
they settle into a lower and lower form
of energy
that's how the molecule wants to exist
gotcha
okay right all right so how does it get
access to that lower form event if you
made the molecule and it's happy here
how does it decide one day to not be
happy it has me
as a father okay it is it is so think of
it
it's in a well but there's a lower well
off to the side how do you get to that
little you have to go up a little hill
before you go down to that lower well
so this molecule has to find a way to
get over that hill and it'll immediately
go to a lower energy state if there's
nothing to stick it over that hill
it would last forever but quantum
physics said
all these molecules and particles are
also waves
and the wave has an existence on the
other side of that hill
and there's a chance that this particle
can disappear from this state and
reappear
on the other side of that hill in a
state where it slides down to a lower
a lower energy level quantum physics
takes it there
it's called tunneling okay so these
bonds that are formed chemically
they're not forever if there's another
bond they could think about
that has a lower energy by the way it
has lower energy it gives off energy
so so this so your food
has complex molecules in it these
protein fibers and
it's it's complex right so given enough
time
quantum physics degrades
the texture of the food
so your meat will still be
meat in five years but you'll start
noticing stockholm you can go
mealy right where's that what's
happening what's happening
why does my meat now taste like soylent
green
because it is
hey what happened to mac the astronaut
where is he well he died
why is this suit still here
so so all i'm saying is food can go bad
biologically
and food can go bad chemically wow
now the you know the lowest energy state
of anything something at absolute zero
uh well yes that's in
by temperature but in terms of uh
configuration the lowest energy state
one of the lowest energy states you can
occupy
is crystal oh crystal form so that's why
it's weird that there's whole there's a
whole
cult around crystals crystals like
i get so much energy crystals have the
lowest energy
of that molecule that's so it's just
weird to
knowing physics and chemistry to see
this unfold that's fine
in this the 21st century but anyhow when
you go to buy salt
are you checking the freshness date on
the soil
have you ever done this are you kidding
me i actually have some jesus salt
in my cupboard
so sorry where do you get salt it gets
mined
from places that have been there for
milli millions of years
okay do you salt that's down below the
ground
right that's just salt it's been there
hadn't been touched that's right okay
it didn't become something else it is
salt it has been salt so
crystalline things like diamonds are
forever diamond as crystal
okay um now i learned that there's
another state of carbon that's a
slightly lower energy than diamond so
diamonds are not actually forever but
they're really really long-lived
okay and so another crystal sugar
okay by the way if sugar goes bad it's
not because it's something to happen to
the crystal because
you put it next to the barbecue pit or
something and it took on the smells
right right or something else was it or
or it absorbed water
somehow yeah exactly so you didn't have
it in a place that was dry enough and
then the other things are what then
messes with it but the sugar crystal
itself is
happy so yes i think salt does have
dates on it but that's just that you can
use it and buy the next one
right better put some more salt on that
man
it's about to go bad
that happened with the tibet with
tabasco sauce i don't think this is
apocryphal i think this is real you know
what happened
you know tobacco sauce the little thing
yeah i love tabasco
you kidding me okay yeah um they figured
out how to double your consumption of
tabasco sauce
how's that someone in the company
suggested
that they make the hole twice as big
brilliant so you still think you're not
using much you're using twice as much as
you use
guess what that makes perfect sense and
they just double the sales and that
person
got a raise
so anyhow so i just want to say that
when food goes bad it can go bad
by the this other way that we don't
think about much but for
very long-term storage like in the
apocalyptic earth this sort of thing
that's how you you would need to think
about that and want to know about but
that'll be true for any
food stuffs at all so you have to watch
out you can't
you can't really stop the quantum
phenomenon from going on
so so it would still taste
like steak but the texture tends to be
one of the things that goes first
so the moral of this story is during the
nuclear apocalypse you better make sure
that you have some salt
because by the way salt itself is a
preservative of other foods
i was about to say because your meat is
going to taste like crap
and your salt's the only thing that's
going to last so
so they have a chuck it so there's a
just a quick one nah that was a good one
i like that
the chemical decomposition of molecules
food molecules molecules in general
that's right yeah
super cool man there you have it all
right there's been another
star talk explainer video neil degrasse
tyson chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure as always keep looking
up